hi guys I am Anna dearman and I'm Chris
Evans we're here with BuzzFeed we're
going to find out how well we know each
other
I know I'm instantly nervous okay
[Music]
their favorite snack to grab at craft
services oh but I do know this but no
but you were on that you were on a crazy
diet what what the hell does it mean
it's not my favorite that's right what
the hell are you eating you do
I think your favorite snack is peanuts
no no M M's no no you don't know me at
all what did you have it's gonna drive
me crazy wait wait you put it in a cup
you eat candy
okay and then I can't check that wait
what do you get on set what was it was
it Cheetos
she wasn't what I was gonna say no oh my
gosh all right next one let's get let's
get to the good one uh they're dogs
I got that that's easy
sauce Roger
Dodger
I mean that counts close enough no
people are gonna hate me now they love
your dog more than anything
all right so I get it I always get them
can I no the town they grew up in Cuba
it's not really a town though is it I
don't know the Town come on man it was a
little down
you know the town I grew up in how could
you be Boston but that's the city you
haven't even sent the city exactly like
and I'm like Boston adjacent at best
Boston so can I check Cuba is a country
it's not even
their favorite memory from knives
how are we supposed to know these
things the day you saw Daniel talking
for the first time that actually is
accurate
yes I'm gonna check it that's impressive
I'm never gonna get it because she was
on the knives out set like for a billion
more days I I worked for like just that
your reaction was
yeah the first time I saw Daniel do his
thing I was like
should I have gone bigger like we had
already shot for three weeks but he was
so good that's active first acting role
definitely don't know I don't know wait
wait wait
I think I just saw what is this movie I
know that you arrive in the car at the
high high school yeah I saw this movie
guys what's the name yeah none of the
Teen Movie is that what it is yeah I
mean that's that's that's well that was
certainly the first movie
um but I don't know I really don't know
hey there's no way I'll know it I mean
it's got to be what was it was a Cuban
film right yeah I mean there's no way
Four Points huh what was it
that's what I was gonna guess
tip of my tongue their favorite ghost is
seeing you filmed together I mean I'll
say the
Beach it was your birthday you got cake
okay fine yeah close enough Fireball
yeah Fireball we had Fireball don't tell
me that it wasn't your favorite yeah
for you
oh
it's the beach yeah me and Roger loved
it favorite character they've ever
played I'm gonna say Captain America
can I say answer me first all right yes
yes that's fair that's accurate God this
is tough It's one of two Marilyn Monroe
or Marta
man it's that's a tough one yeah that's
a really I don't think I can choose so
you're allowed to all right so that's
kind of accurate yeah yeah there's
signature dish to cook
do you even cook no yeah
so that's correct right peanut butter
toast yeah
um I'll say Frijoles
[Laughter]
she ate a lot of Frijoles on knives out
oh yeah
that is horrible
I don't know your signature to cook what
is it I think I would say chicken soup
chicken soup you have no idea how good
my chicken soup is really wow another
level what are we doing for lunch
their go-to karaoke song you couldn't
you couldn't if I have more Fireballs
why would I do anything's possible
problem is I have too many you seem to
just curious I I know I can't get me to
stop
much to the dismay of everyone present I
don't know that I have a go-to karaoke
song to be fair but I do love karaoke so
I don't know if this one quite Works do
you don't know mine do you have one yeah
really what is it
switch out of mine really bold
clearly I have to be really drunk to do
that I don't know if there's a fireball
in the world uh okay then we didn't know
that one
first celebrity crush
give me a hint
TV movies movies American yeah my age no
older I was a kid and he was amazing now
I just want to know who Tom Hanks
[Music]
that's good for Tom Hanks who was yours
I feel like someone like Kylie Minogue
or something no the first celebrity
crush was probably Elizabeth's shoe you
know what I mean I'm an 80s kid that was
you know karate kid cocktail yeah
the last book they read
that that's me
the last text they sent you oh about
dinner
there was you know that yeah we know
that books texts got it all right okay
so I know she had it on ghosted March
April May and this towards the end of
filming is it in May no but you're close
is it in April
no but it's a month it's definitely a
month you're like really really close
April very close
yeah it's April oh it's April okay how
about 17th no closer to May
28th closer 29th how many days in April
30th is it really yeah I knew it almost
may I
um yes
oh gray man I turned 40. June June June
that's right it's June 15th 13th
you get that point more than that oh
come on don't you remember good for you
for remembering that that's right I
turned 40. so I'm gonna Mark that yeah
yeah okay
we have horrible score yep not good six
out of 13. I'll sign and this is way too
complimentary 6 out of 13 it's like do
you even know this person as your
friendship grows you're just sometimes
it's just the simple things like I feel
like I did know your dog's name it was
my is my English it's the pronunciation
I meant to say
the truth is you do know doctor I mean
yeah of course
we know each other better than this yeah
this isn't fair like there's there's
more cooler things that we know thank
you for this game and make sure to watch
ghosted April 21st check it out on Apple
Plus
[Music]
foreign